let's talk a little bit about the
special master that has been appointed
by judge eileen cannon to oversee the
documents seized at donald trump's house
uh there's really no way to put it
lightly
uh best levin has a very good article in
vanity fair called trump's special
master situation is shady as f
according to legal experts now i
encourage you
to check out the entire article because
it will go into a lot more detail than i
will go into today but as many of you
who have emailed me have suspected
the legal reasoning for the special
master being granted is extraordinarily
shaky and as many legal experts have
weighed in it will really do nothing
other than slightly delay the process
of this criminal investigation into
donald trump now that shouldn't be
dismissed as nothing donald trump's
strategy for many years legally has been
delay any opportunity you have to delay
is good and most lawyers will agree that
at least as far as the clients they
represent right uh if you ask them about
some case they're not involved in
most of them will say you know the delay
tactics don't typically help over the
long term but
there are lawyers who will say well
listen what i know is if i can delay i
give myself an opportunity to mount to
better defense allow people to quit
retire get bored get frustrated whatever
so delay is usually considered something
that
lawyers like to do and that they can
bill for by the way so best levin
reports judge eileen cannon a granted
this request from donald trump's legal
team for a special master a special
master reviews the documents holds and
reviews the documents in this case it's
11 000 government documents that were
seized from mar-a-lago on august 8th and
the reason that this is advantageous to
trump at least in theory is that while
the documents are under the review of
the special master prosecutors can't
continue using those documents and
examining the documents for their
criminal investigation the review has to
happen first
trump's claim
is that some of the materials are
covered by executive privilege
some of the materials are
medical documents etc
legal experts by and large believe that
the ruling is absurd for a couple of
different reasons first let's start with
samuel buell who's a duke university law
professor he spoke to the new york times
and said quote
to any lawyer with serious federal
criminal court experience who is being
honest this ruling is laughably bad and
the written justification is even
flimsier donald trump is getting
something no one else ever gets in
federal court he's getting it for no
good reason and it will not in the
slightest reduce the ongoing howls that
he is being persecuted when he is being
privileged that's a really important
point
trump's story is i am being treated
uniquely terribly by the justice system
the reality is he's being treated
uniquely well
the fact that the justice department and
fbi
waited so long
to do the search warrant after they
requested the documents from trump under
subpoena and they weren't turned over
that is a privilege that was granted to
donald trump the fact that the special
master has been appointed is a privilege
for donald trump
constitutional law professor lawrence
tribe wrote about judge eileen cannon's
decision her decision was utterly
lawless she is disgraced she has
disgraced her position
as an article 3 judge
and then
u.s former u.s acting solicitor
general neil katyal
wrote on twitter
this special master opinion is so bad
it's hard to know where to begin
she says biden hasn't weighed in on
whether documents are protected by
executive privilege nonsense the
archives letter makes it clear the
current president thinks none of this is
privileged the archivist says it is not
a close question
two the judge enjoins the entire
investigation because some of the
material might be subject to executive
privilege but executive privilege isn't
some post-presidential privilege that
allows presidents to keep documents
after they leave office
at most it simply means these are
executive documents that must be
returned to the archives it doesn't in
any way shape or form mean they can't be
used in a criminal prosecution about
stolen documents and lastly this is an
important point judge cannon said that
the reputational harm to trump from the
documents
justifies a special master and katyal
says that's insane every criminal
defendant has reputational harm are we
now going to have special masters in
every criminal investigation and that's
a really important point
one of the big
statements made by judge eileen cannon
is
the reputational harm that trump would
suffer or might suffer from these
documents being given to the fbi
potentially made public etc
justifies a special master getting all
the documents and reviewing them
arguably any time you are
raided and potentially indicted
by the federal government
you're going to suffer reputationally
even if the charges are ultimately
dropped
this is one of the things that is sort
of a
i don't know what to call it a calling
card it's it's a feature
or a bug whatever of our justice system
which is sometimes people are arrested
and charged and then they are found not
guilty or charges are dismissed and
there is still the risk of and sometimes
there really is reputational harm if
you're accused of murder
and charged with murder
and then there's a lengthy trial and
you're acquitted
it's not like everything goes back to
zero because you were found not guilty
and you can argue that that's a problem
with our justice system it's a problem
arguably with many justice systems which
is you can be charged and and there can
be a trial and then you're acquitted but
the fact that you were charged still
hurts you in some way reputationally
it's not unique to donald trump and the
idea as neil katyal points out
arguably anytime this happens to any
defendant there's reputational harm
you're not going to grant a special
master in all cases is another one of
the signs that donald trump isn't being
persecuted unfairly he's actually being
privileged he is being deferred to and
given things that so many others and so
many other defendants are not